no slope a nice straight cut thank you I
felt good because the knife but you
smushed the bread
you're in charge of food I've been
planning a nuptial menu since the day I
met Genevieve warning it will be
delicious and highly erotic your menu is
not going to involve animal genitalia is
it no I was gonna make
not that
Amy Gina you came he's a good Miss
opening day of your food truck or your
biggest and also your biggest investor I
guess she was freaking out she was gonna
lose a ton of money I told you
we don't have that kind of relationship
well don't worry I'm feeling good the
one thing truck is ready to serve the
one thing yeah we only serve one thing
the perfect meatball sandwich made
exactly the way Nana Boyle used to I
can't believe this is finally happening
sorry I'm a bit stressed Jason and Jeff
the guys I hired to work a truck called
in sick so I'm all alone what a fun
opportunity okay Boyle stop freaking out
I have the day off I can step in and
help yeah me too I'm not off but I come
and go as I please it's part of my charm
like an outdoor cat
okay I think we're ready for a practice
sandwich sounds good boss just call me
chef
Chef thank you
okay see
a little slopey I want you to cut it
straight across no big deal
again
[Music]
soapy don't overthink it
you're not thinking enough
okay
still sloppy again
you know what why don't we try this why
don't you just take that knife put it to
my throat and finish the job do I look
like [ __ ] to you do I look like Jake to
you no not at all then why are you
trying to screw me oh my God Charles
what is going on with you it's Chuck
you're not ready for this Gina you're up
okay but I'm not calling you chef and
you're not yelling at me
there you go thank you no slope a nice
straight cut thank you I felt good
because the knife but you smushed the
bread it's too smushy
again order up chef
what is this why are you making six
sandwiches at once it's more efficient
now we're ready for the next five
customers who gives a hump about
efficiency the perfect meatball sandwich
is sauce exactly 70 seconds before being
served to maintain bread Integrity so
sandwich number one would be fine but
sandwich number six will be a soggy turd
change in menu we're serving soggy turds
now get them while they're wet okay I
quit me too you're insane fine quit just
like Jeff and Jason did you told us they
got sick they got sick of hard work just
like you two get out you'll never cook
in this town again we're not chefs and
you never will be Amy will you taste
this batter
hmm I think it's a little off you know
what's off your mouth why Jake lets your
stupid tongue anywhere near him I'll
never know nope I forgot the sugar
that's on me hello Boyle after you're
done here meet me in my office I have
something I need to ask you it's food
related
I will bring my A-game
I got Gina Captain Holt just asked me
into his office for a food related
question yes I heard and that's how I
know I don't care I've wanted to build a
rapport with him since he got here but
until now all we've had in common was
our bank
guess who NYPD heads up
this is great I had no idea Captain Holt
was interested in food I have zero
interest in food if it were feasible my
diet would consist entirely of a
flavorless beige smoothies containing
all the nutrients required by the human
animal
so our bank got some new ATMs huh I
wouldn't know I've switched banks ah no
anyway tomorrow's my anniversary with
Kevin I'd like to cook him an impressive
breakfast could you help Orient me with
that process I'd be honored preparing
food for once lover is the most intimate
gift of all
aside from washing their hair
you know many people think that
scrambled eggs are the easiest food to
make that is incredibly foolish they are
a highly nuanced and complicated dish
okay now go ahead and pour your eggs
right into the pan nice and slow
oh okay now what do I do oh boy okay we
hear that Sizzle that means the heat is
a little too high on those eggs well the
the higher the heat the faster the eggs
cooked the sooner Kevin eats am I
incorrect no you make an excellent point
but we don't want to feed Kevin burned
garbage cooking is about patience are
you completely insane you never salt can
a pan to hand the hand is the middle man
okay
what you did is the culinary equivalent
of unprotected sex
you know what you sir are not ready to
scramble eggs
hand over your spatula
fun
I only wish in return I could get back
all the time I just wasted on this
futile project
I'm just going to make Kevin plain toast
for breakfast oh
that is low hey boy I smell Bernie is
Hitchcock roasting corn on the radiator
again no
what you smell is the burning wreckage
of my relationship with Holt so there's
no corn on the cob sorry I'm late guys
how to get my ax sharpened why do you
have an ax also nice ax thank you it's
for the turkey so I can chop its head
off when it gets here chop its head off
I ordered a live turkey it's being
delivered because you know what they say
the yummiest turkey is the one that just
died in your hands Charles you can't
kill an animal in here that's horrible
it's disgusting we won't let you do it
right Amy it's getting late don't make a
mess relax it's not the first turkey
I've killed in a friend's bathtub it
isn't
hey Rosa the Flatbush Diner's pie is
terrible it's inedible food is supposed
to be edible so you were lying what the
hell Boyle
put it in the second bucket
bucket crust isn't any better it's
fancier but it's all bells and whistles
desserts don't need to be clever they
just need to be good this is the best
pie in New York City Apple from Argos
Bakery founded 1910 recipe unchanged
taste it
is amazing this part is so good I hate
it you just graduated high school
[ __ ] sorry I said [ __ ] I'm just
really worked up
I can't believe Sal's is gone this place
is an institution it's the best pizza in
the neighborhood
the best
yeah a tragedy I mean any food related
crime is a tragedy like I said Sal's is
an institution and it's the best pizza
in the neighborhood I'm sorry Jake Sal's
only the eighth best I put out a weekly
Brooklyn Pizza ranking email blast sales
has the fourth best texture ninth best
crust 12 best cheese and honestly
they're only seventh in mouth feel mouth
feel what is that the inside of your
cheeks are very sensitive it's like the
inside of your thighs except with the
tongue oh god look no Mario the pine
needs work good consistency on the crust
with the cheese and sauce ratio to
travesty
do you have to spit in a word yes
amateurs go tasting they fill up and
they lose their palate by the third
slice I take this very seriously why are
you dragging Sal's pizzas through the
mud that place is special why is it
special because it's the best pizza in
the neighborhood well according to
Charles's email blast it's actually
number eight Captain reads my blast of
course it's the only one that measures
mouthfeel are you kidding right now now
the first step in learning how to cook
is learning how to taste so close your
eyes and open your mouth this isn't
Burning Man boil
tell me what I'm eating fine it's a
sharp Vermont Cabot
now describe what you taste
jeez
and
jeez okay that's good but try being more
descriptive I know you love peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches why
their components have a long shelf life
they are cost effective and they're so
simple a child could make them okay I
was looking for more of an emotional
connection for example my favorite meal
is a simple roast chicken and potatoes
it was the only dish my mother knew how
to cook and when I eat it I feel as
though I am once again inside her womb
what's your story behind a PB J
I want a sandwich I make a sandwich I
eat
the sandwich Bongiorno Bongiorno pretty
cool stoom huh stem short for costume ah
all right let me guess you are dumpy
Chuck Norris no don't be Ron Weasley no
you guys stop it he put thought into his
costume and he is obviously Miranda from
Sex in the City guys I'm Mario Batali
Malto Mario celebrity chef Ginger Prince
of Little Italy is he also a homeless
troll doll because you look like a
homeless troll doll a sweet potato
costume dude thank you there's a man
with impeccable taste he bit a guy's
butt off at a WNBA game
air assaults from mask I'll take it